By 2039, the world will look
and feel very different.
The rate of change
is itself speeding up
and 20 years from now power
will have shifted dramatically.
So who might be up and who might be
down, twenty years from now?
Let me take you on a journey
of possibles.
Up, Africa.
A rapidly increasing population
could fuel Africa's
surging economic growth.
With a pool of young, better educated
and globally connected workers.
But the biggest revolution in Africa
might be the spread of vast, super
arrays of far cheaper solar panels.
To quote one energy guru...
Also up, China.
THE superpower.
After cornering many of the worlds
vital raw materials,
could it now control both its own
people and many other countries
struggling to repay its loans.
Could we see a world where China
exerts its influence
through movies and music too?
But if there are winners, which
countries could be losers by 2039?
Down, perhaps most of Europe.
Financial services and banking will
be overwhelmingly driven by A.I.
So Europe loses much of its
global edge.
Parents who once urged children to
become lawyers and doctors,
beg them to become
designers, artists, even actors.
Anything creative -
not easily done by robots.
Down but not out,
the United States of America.
Eclipsed by China and paying a price
for getting late to wind and solar.
Also down, the Middle East.
Largely ignored internationally
because no one needs its
oil and gas anymore.
Fossil fuels have become
the new forbidden fruit.
Oil has lost most of its value,
alternative fuels plus a collapse in
the use of plastics has seen to that.
Water, clean water,
will be more precious than ever.
Water wars have replaced oil wars,
along the Nile or any mighty river.
Conflicts could break out
as states closest to the sea
fight those further upstream, accused
of taking too much of the water.
Data however will be king.
By 2039, more and more is being
bought and sold.
Mostly illegally and in secret.
All governments will rely on data as
THE method of control.
Some countries will have followed
the Scandinavian lead.
By choosing near total transparency -
of tax returns, earnings, lifestyles
to reduce the secret data threat.
And more and more citizens everywhere
could be fighting back -
becoming data refuseniks.
Fed up with the negative effects
of social media,
will they simply abandon
cyber space wherever they can?
Minimising their electronic footprint
even reverting to writing and
delivering private messages by hand.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)